زياره ليليه مفاجئه قام فيها الرئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني الى
مستشفى الكاظميه في يومين للوقوف على
احوال المستشفى والخدمات
هناك مقاطع عديده متداوله من الزياره
حولتها لا عنوان رئيسي بين العراقيين خاصه
جمله معينه غير متوقعه اختصر فيها رئيس
الحكومه الوضع بالمختصر المفيد زينب
بيقولوا
حقيقي يتفرج الله يوفقك الله يوفقك
حتى تصاحبي الله يوفقك
الحكومه
لكن شملت كمان الوجبات المقدمه للمرضى
واللي كشفت طبعا ايضا حقيقه مره
مستشفى المستشفى
بالمواقعهم لمواقع اخرى كاجراء تاذيبي
الاطباء
الميه قسم للمحموديه وقسم لابو غريب ثلاث
وجبات حسب
الاطباء والامام موجودين
الطارميه المحموديه ابو غريب
كلها قسمت اراء العراقيين يعني في شريحه
رحبت بالتحرك من رئيس الحكومه بس في
ثانيين شافوا انه هذه الزياره هي استعراض
شو اعلامي بس قالوا انه يعني الاوضاع في
القطاع الصحي معروفه وفي معظم المستشفيات
مش بس في مستشفى واحد
والموضوعيه ليصير في تحرك وتحسين وتغيير
هذا غير اخرين شاف وايضا انه يعني اذا في
كوادر مقصره في هذا المكان ونقلناها لمكان
اخر وين الفائده